that's what I'm talking about money
money what's the matter with you milk
I repent hummus for a cool minute any
time y'all let me say it come on my dude
we can't just let you say that word is
sacred I'll do whatever y'all want if
y'all let me say anything just name I'm
gonna need all your love just for the
rest of the school year and I'm taking
your man boo for a wicked turn you might
want to scrub all them hos out first
dough with sanitizer you don't get it
girl believe ya I want to see that pic
of your mom smelly John mmm well I guess
you can say it now fine but just this
one time
oh hell Jess I've been waiting my whole
life for this
ready on three one two three
legend what y'all thought I was free the
same
[Music]